um talk about unnv's relationship
obviously man you guys have uh
like I said earlier you guys have built
up something really incredible
um how did you guys initially link up
and was it like I mean he's always been
an entrepreneur right like um he's
always been on top of his [ __ ] but like
um your guys's relationship how did that
start what was that so I met MB right
I've been to real estate before I met
him I've been to real estate give and
take
back then about 12 years right yeah
um
and I met him through one of my good
friends which is knit the grit and uh
Danny zoo litigrant and Danny Zoo uh
they own the label where uh fetty WAP
was signed to okay yeah 1738 yeah 1738.
so that that makes sense Patterson yeah
and you know we're all from Patterson
right and I helped them with a lot of
their Investments too early on and
that's how uh they introduced me to to
Zia yeah yeah and then says that
um he told me yo you got a pretty dope
story
it was never in my cars to be a public
speaker right I was never thinking about
that uh we announced on Instagram right
no marketing nothing just videos with
iPhone we're having a real estate
seminar 500 people showed up
he threw me in from this no you know
it's funny that MV didn't give me no
pointers didn't tell me anything just
gave me the mic and told me go ahead
figure it out figure it out bro I went
out there man my throat got dry I
couldn't talk for like the first two
minutes I was looking at my wife I was
like I hope she brings me some water
yeah right and um since that man we had
180 000 people come to our real estate
seminars wow uh about 200 million
dollars worth of wealth was built in our
communities for people that invested in
real estate in our through the seminars
wow so like for people who because you
know I think that some of these
sometimes when you think of like
seminars in general right
there is some stigma that comes with
those because there's people who do like
seminars but it it feels like an
extremely
um I wouldn't say a scam right but like
there's there's like a lot of these
self-help guys who will have a seminar
and like I'm not sure what you're taking
from it except for coming out of it like
super inspired when you guys do a
seminar you guys are literally teaching
yep black and white very applicable
things yeah so we break everything down
right we start with credit right because
credit is very important yeah right
especially you know we teach you about
your personal credit we teach you about
business credit we start with that from
there uh we have a a mortgage person
right it's how you have how to qualify
what do you need then we'll have a real
estate attorney we'll have a real estate
broker in that area right that knows
that market we'll have our friends from
auction.com they're talking about their
inventory we'll have a hard money lender
and explain to people how that process
is wow we'll have a contractor there and
then at the end we tell our stories and
our seminars there is no upsell so you
pay anywhere between 100 to 300 a ticket
and that's it that's it there's no like
hey yeah I'm not trying to sell you a
course right I'm not telling you hey if
you really wanted me flipping MJ and DJ
Envy during the next seminar right there
in the next seminar with us tonight you
know yeah because that's the thing too
man I've been to a couple of seminars
where you go and they announced these
people they're gonna be there and
they're not there listen I have a friend
of mine who is absolutely obsessed with
Grant Cardone and he has spent
ridiculous amounts of money to hang out
with him at these like I'm talking about
like
stupid money like to just hang out with
Grant Cardone I'm like wait he's like
you know taking selfies with them
they're eating dinner and I'm like bro
how much did that cost like it's wild
when I see [ __ ] like that I'm just like
hmm when you think about it man right
now you know to be honest with your
grand card don't it's kind of like what
Trump was right at one point Trump was
kind of like the face of real estate in
the US right right yeah Grant's
definitely that face yeah he's
definitely that face right now yeah he
got it and he's running I mean he's
running it up God bless him man but yeah
I think like uh you know I just think
that's dope man for you like uh the
seminar thing obviously
when did you guys feel like you kind of
mastered that because like you said it
didn't start off like you started off
with 500 people yeah like when did you
guys realize like oh right like the
first year in right and then we were
even gonna go harder the next year but
then Kobe hit yeah we started doing
webinars and stuff like that but now
it's a little weird right uh we're not
doing as many seminars as we used to
because it's over saturated everybody
now right in the age of social media is
like let's say they sell one house
they're an expert they do one stock
trade they're an expert right they have
one truck they're expert everybody wants
to sell a course everybody wants to do a
seminar so people have to be very
careful because a lot a lot of times you
go to these events into these uh places
and they don't really know what they're
talking about so it's cool right that me
and MV made it cool where people that
look like us to do you know seminars
could be involved in that kind of the
business you know could promote things
like that which is awesome but then we
also made it too easy right well now
anybody thinks they could do it right
and even though they're not really doing
it it looks like that you know because
the age of social media you don't know
who's doing what yeah right
um for people who